welcome to this video coverage for the
13th round of this candidates tournament
and this is about the game I'm draken
playing white against their own young
playing black yeah well under Reagan is
on now I need to think about this minus
10 is a tough to keep the standings in
my head minus 1 and Aronian is on plus 1
so he's at least got the theoretical
chance before this game to overtake
Arnold he's trading on on by one point
so in case unanswered lose against
kayaking in this round aronian where the
win could actually tie the score so he
basically needs to play in a way that
keeps his options open trying to try to
win if Allen should make some some
mistake in this game so let's see what
happens d 4 plate 96 and Bishop g5 the
Trump askia tech or Trump aus key attack
and this is one of and ray Kinsella
burnings he had to plate the trampled
scheme and also related openings like
this the torrian tech very successfully
in the world cup tournament last year in
in terms o tromso norway um he played
this very successfully in his rapid
games and also tournament games beating
many strong players with those kind of
yeah kind of let's say slightly offbeat
openings it's not it's not like let's
say very rare or very exotic but still
not thought to be very critical but he
got quite playable positions and scored
really heavily so what has aronian
prepared for this he suddenly needed to
prepare some
against the Trump offski plate the move
g6 after three minutes which sits a bit
strange to be honest I mean it was
certainly one of the openings that could
be expected of course I know Andre Cain
is playing all kinds of openings he's
played Annie 4d for another three
everything but there was some likelihood
that this opening should could rise so
always surprised that they take some
time sometimes in the very first moves
well you never know maybe he was just I
don't know getting a new coffee because
of the one he got was cold or so but ok
let's see what happens why takes and he
takes f g six is obviously inviting the
capture it's basically saying okay I'm
just ignoring what you're doing and
please take so I get the bishops okay
and Dragon was happy to oblige took on
f6 and now played the move see form yeah
here and there's an interesting I am
interesting a question how wide should
set up his pieces and in what particular
move order he should do that it's pretty
clear that after this capture White has
a set up that he would like to play but
how exactly in which move order is the
question and a very normal way to do it
is like that I'm just putting it on the
board let's say III Bishop g7 g3 castle
and specialty to F 592 36 c4c 693 this
is why it set up this is what he wants
to do and generally speaking this is a
pretty comfortable setup for white I
actually have played this on the black
site a couple of times not in tournament
chess but in in in blitz when I was
looking for some easier antidote against
the [ __ ] all ski I thought well maybe
g6 is the kind of move that it's a bit
of an in-your-face move like okay I
don't care what you're doing just
take it and I don't care but the reality
is that this type of position is rather
comfortable for white he's got a
ready-made plan like rook b1 b4 b5 this
is just a a good piece on on g2 and
black structure is not not so healthy
the the double porn itself is not such a
problem it's not not too bleak double
bond but it restricts this bishop and
you don't really know what to do with
this piece it's not a very comfortable
position and in my opinion the question
whether is what move water exactly and
under aching is now playing playing it
with C form and this is interesting it's
not the most common move order the one
that I actually just put on the board
with e3 and g3 is Sam is more more usual
but what it does is if you start with
you three black might actually decide
that Bishop g7 is not such a great thing
after all and my play d5 and then we got
an entirely a different type of type of
game where let's say something like that
could happen just to show on something
completely different and now black
castles place at five we have an open
center or let's say a more open center
now and why does not bein shadowed it
leads to completely a different position
that blight black might prefer to the
set up with f5 that hasn't showed with
effort Bishop g7 and worked it under
again do we played c4s mention and this
is interesting because it's directed
against those kind of early d 5 moves
now we five I mean okay this cannot be
so great because you just take on d5 so
it's not so clear what black should do
now you can always switch back to this
but probably not what what you want to
do yeah aronian did something else she
gave this check after some thought so he
was basically at this more
and playing on his own not based on any
sort of preparation we are also already
in pretty much unknown unknown territory
this is almost never played in my
database of what is this 6 million games
or something there are four games with
this position so they both needed to
think on their own um and to be honest I
don't like at all what our own head is
now doing he gives okay he gave the
check okay 922 and now he played the
move c5 which probably was the plan when
he went for this check but I don't know
yeah well I will player that I try to
keep keeping a healthy pawn structure
and a simply simply don't think that
this could be a healthy structure after
a three he also needs to take I mean
he's giving up his his Bishop check I
mean okay it's a bishop pair so the the
Trump that black got blacks Trump in the
Trump very often is the bishop pair and
he gave it away now to Conde for three
year we gone to this position and this
simply looks looks very uncomfortable to
me it's also now very tricky out to get
even get your yo be a [ __ ] about I mean
what he did I think it's the relatively
best solution at 2pm check gave this
check and I put the Queen only five but
what kind of opening result is that
blackest has got this bad bishop 1c8
it's got a destroyed pawn structure and
I mean I was mentioning that black
ideally would have some kind of winning
option in this game trying to I don't
know somehow do something because in
case uh none to losses and so on but how
is black ever going to win a game in
in this position so I think it's just a
bit of an opening mishap by Aronian here
somewhat I don't know incomplete or
strange preparation and this seems seems
very very comfortable for white yeah and
drinking now castled long which looks
funny with this with this open situation
on the queenside but ok his king is
still perfectly safe there also was the
move rookie one which seems quite
promising ok but long castles and now a
five yeah black must do something so we
try to open up the Queen side which was
denied b5 plate now d 6 yeah of course
if white now takes check check
everything's more than fine for black so
26 of course to be avoided check but he
just he just took only five and now
played g3 trying to get the bishop on
this long diagonal yeah this position I
think should be should be slightly
better for white I mean as mentioned i
didn't like his his his play blacks play
but it's not like it's disastrously bad
his position it just feels like like it
does not have much in terms of terms of
active play um there should be six
Bishop g2 this is just a very strong
bishop on g2 aronia took on one c4 which
is probably the way to go not much else
takes on b7 check now this this check
yeah what what is happening now the b5
pond is attacked and white only really
has one way one way to play this and
this is with a for Bishop b3 and this of
course has needed what's needed to
calculate beforehand this is a double
attack on the rook and the pawn on f4
and and Reagan is going for an exchange
sacrifice not a very difficult
decision to be honest because you quite
clearly see that after this capture and
rook takes which is not played in the
game um that after this that white has a
very substantial compensation this is in
itself quite good limiting blacks rooks
and it's stained respond but white only
has also has this idea of course getting
at the e5 pawn and the feem wins the
spawn two connected passes on the
queenside are super strong and there
also is this idea to march up the King
all the way to c5 push the pawn and
white has very definite compensation we
can continue this line because this is a
critical position of the game really as
Aronian did not take the exchange but ok
let's look at this a bit more it's also
easy to determine what the blacks best
plan is I actually liked the suggestion
of the engineer for dinis to play h5 the
idea is to push quickly each form and
activate the rook right from the H file
if white goes H form you can play g5 and
activate like that yeah trying to take
and actually go rook GA g form sorry
intervals too much too many moves back
so I think white should probably allow
h4 not go edge for himself um and yeah
this means that probably look the 7s the
move to look at let's say H form and
this is not not forced I'm just trying
to to show um a simple line if white now
goes some on hunting like has got very
quick play with Luke to h2 and I'm not
sure that this is a good idea for white
this could easily backfire for instance
if I really take now there's rook f2
when you cannot even keep eatin I mean
this is not really a moose
probably rook a seven is too greedy and
to Bishop g5 is to be preferred
attacking on on f7 um yeah here check
after this let's say the situation is
not clear to me it's a after Roxy form
that's Ruby for for example after Bishop
c4 this route before a black has
definite counter play and I'm not sure
really if why does any any real
advantage here it's just very
complicated and can be continued but I
don't want to do a 10 for a deep line in
any case I think huronian should have
crept the exchange he took on a form and
after Luke d5 you have a big problem b5
is now protected and this Bishop is very
much offside King e7 plate enter King to
a 3 yeah can you trap can you trap the
the bishop serve as a big question what
about rook a one here for example this
Bishop does not have any square but
black has the smooth very good defensive
idea threatening rook takes c6 and here
it's quite funny White has no way to to
move the bishop to some some meaningful
spot if you go king here this Bishop b3
in the quite funny move yeah again using
this pin okay one that's not a knob that
promising he played a king to worm to a3
purchase the right move Bishop Moscow
here check whooped his heaven check came
back to evade and now I'm he played the
move from efore yeah here you can argue
it's possible that maybe Bishop d5 was
was even stronger after Bishop d5
look Abby 5 and Roxy one it's it's
interesting because black now can
sacrifice back here on d5 and now we
treat with the bishop and I'm not 100%
sure that this is actually a win for
white it might be it might be but I'm
not on not one hundred percent sure it's
in essence and an exchange app because
Loki em Dwight will also gain the this
pawn of course let's say yeah let's go
there immediately and this could be a
win because f6 might fall and if F 6
volts like King all the way here and
they take it with the rook twice then
then this might be a real win other than
that it could be could be tricky um
maybe I'm dragon wasn't 100% sure about
that and he went before for that reason
it keeps the whites advantage intact a
for Bishop to be three yeah they went to
this this double rook endgame which is
of course still very very favorable for
white it's it's I'm not sure if it is a
winning position but it's very very
close check let's continue for a bit and
up to this up to this point exactly here
is a critical spot again they both work
a bit low on time five minutes something
left so not a really comfortable
situation in this position aronian
needed to play rook to be eight just
basically staying and not not doing
anything okay White is better adesso
there's this um dangerous pawn on d6 so
no question is that white is calling the
shots here but
the thing is what he did is he took on
f2 as mentioned not with so much so much
time available but this is simply a
direct loss because white now invades
with the King this is why I needed to
stay on the C file and now this is an
important move through a to a five
always allowing for this brooke shields
if black is going for for any checks IAM
check this was played 26 check ya little
time so we can easily reach a hit once
mm-hmm and now white is ready to march
the pawns check here we go and in case
of this you always just have group to be
five check this was in fact plate check
check and here aronian resigned there is
nothing left you can go here this luke a
eight coming yeah check it it was really
decisive that he allowed the White King
to to enter with rupee eight he could
have put up still some some resistance
it would have been a very uncomfortable
position but still possible to to to
fight to fight for a bit yeah some never
really puzzled about this opening I mean
if you really wanted to have some sort
of charts to win I think this is really
a bit of a bit of a non-starter and it
really it really felt like he didn't
have anything great prepared and get
prepared against the did against the
Trump I mean this is surprising it's one
of his one of andre kins openings and
there are many lines available for black
that can lead to some somewhat more
dynamic play yeah like let's say I'm
let's
c5 for example trying to provoke this
Capshaw do something like that which
admittedly is dangerous business but ok
you want to win a game you need to need
to risk something alright so a loss for
aronian which means he's out of it
regardless of what a nerd is doing he's
falling back to a 50-percent score with
that one a draicon is on fifty percent
now he really has fought back and in
general I think he would yeah I at least
I assume that he considers this
tournament to be a success for him he's
on fifty percent now in the toughest
possible field imaginable really ok yeah
we don't have cards and we don't have la
cameras what's whatever but it's a super
strong tournament he does not have much
experience in those and getting to fifty
percent over this over 13 games is
really a good result for him and of
course a good win in this game why
feronia and this tournament is very
disappointing again like just like last
year all right I do a resume of the the
tournament anyway resume so some English
word i'll do i do a summary of the whole
tournament anyway in the final videos
for around 14 alright thanks for
watching